and first from our 8 news now
investigators it was a mass shooting at
an unlicensed hookah lounge just off the
strip involving a man with more than 80
previous arrests right now that man is
behind bars on a much different charge
than he originally faced eight news now
investigator David charns explains 45
year old Lee Wilson is the only person
charged in the mass shooting that
happened inside this now closed hookah
lounge he took a plea deal sending him
to prison for what could end up being a
year Behind Bars
foreign
police originally charged to Lee Wilson
with murder for the February shooting
inside this unlicensed hookah lounge 33
year old Demetrius beer died from his
injuries 13 others including Wilson were
shot crime scene photos the 8 news now
investigators obtained last year showed
the damage as several people fired
during a birthday party County officials
say the lounge was serving alcohol in
hookah and operating as a nightclub all
without the proper licenses
Wilson took a deal on a much lesser
charge of owning a firearm by a
prohibited person video from this
December 2018 shooting shows Wilson and
two other men firing their guns outside
this bar just west of the strip that
arrest one of 82 in Wilson's record
Wilson was out of custody before
Wednesday's hearing a judge allowing him
to get medical treatment before
beginning his prison sentence
investigators suspect there were as many
as five shooters that night and it's
unclear who Wilson hit when he fired
Metro telling me they continued to
investigate and identify those
outstanding suspects near Sahara and
Maryland Parkway I'm David charns 8 News
Now
now that plea deal puts Wilson behind
bars for 21 up to 54 months but with
credit for time served Wilson could
spend just a year and a half in prison
our 8 news now investigators broke
several developments in the story
including the fact there were several
Shooters as the story continues to
develop you can find all the information
as well as breaking news push alerts
inside of our 8 News Now app it's
available for free inside the both
Google Play and App Store